welcome and good morning I'm Ron York so
coach heir of the foreign language oh
thank you so much I can't tell you how
great it is to see an audience that's
raring to go at 10 a.m. but that's the
kind of people who really love foreign
language films and and we've been so
pleased by it all year all year long
this morning is slightly renamed Oscar
celebrates foreign language films you'll
notice it's a lot like symposia of
previous years only even more festive
I'd like to acknowledge my superb
co-chair Bruce Davis
we really had a wonderful time going on
this long compressed journey of
nominating the five films and we
couldn't have done it without the
support from the Academy and
particularly taurine and Meredith it has
been for so many of you in the audience
a long process I know many of you were
in the lobby at 11 o'clock at night
having just seen the second of a double
bill of foreign language films we feel
like we've all gone through that
together and I'd really like all the
members of the general committee and the
executive committee to please stand up
and be acknowledged
we are very fortunate today to have
celebrated director Angley with us
he's a true champion of the foreign
language category he's been nominated
three times he's won Oscar in that
category he jumped out of the category
and won an Oscar again for Brokeback
Mountain and this year he's nominated
once again for the extraordinary Life of
Pi
please welcome Angley
thank you
thank you thank you very kind of you
my job here is actually for the first
time for this character for this event
to to welcome you to his symposium to me
this is a very sweet homecoming my
relationship with the Oscar star here
with the foreign language film
I was very foreign 1993 with a wedding
banquet there's a lot of fun I didn't
win that a year but I had a blast
really Oscar growing up watching the
show like every every filmmaker can
dream about thanking their beloved ones
their fellow filmmakers in front of the
whole world on - on this show so I was
actually here but foreign like on the I
thought it was the sidebar lots of fond
memories I live on the stage I was still
struggling with English and when we're
asked the first question what does Oscar
mean to you and I struggle with broken
English saying that for the first time
my wife has to worry about what she's
gonna wear I was very honest very green
and sitting next to me was even a
quieter Vietnamese director chant it did
a movie called green papaya great film
and I felt very much like a green papaya
see hopefully but there are great events
at a lunch and they're very nice invite
our Idol directors such as Billie wider
rubber wise they're all they're real
person talking to us eating with us I
still remember this the spaghetti that
the pasta we ate that lunch it was like
a dream come true
and then finally the event I never saw
so many starter life that passing right
in front of my eyes it was something you
know that's not why I make movies for
well that was quite fulfilling many
years past the third time I'm here I was
with Crouching Tiger Hidden Dragon thank
you
that was a strange experience that was
indeed a Chinese language film but were
also offered my other category in the
Oscar so it was a really mixture for me
things started bland for me I spoke
better English then but coming years I
still felt most comfortable and most at
home and then things started playing
together I see a movie globalized right
in front of my eyes I start to see
myself doing my Chinese films with
American film language arts doing
english-language films such as Brokeback
with Chinese heart you know things all
blend together I don't know what's
falling anymore I'm just making movies
and this last movie I did like a pie in
my heart it's it's not foreign language
but really a foreign film Indian cast
Canadian writer was shot in Taiwan you
know with the Indian cast and 24 people
from 24 country make the movies together
it was really an international movie
especially how they work around the
world in the box office just culturally
it's really a world movie so as I see
we're embracing the world and were blind
together I also know it's something that
doesn't change the more we do that the
more we actually appreciate individual
cultures and film special filmmaking's
that's happened at the same time
what I really want to say is that I I
noticed something that is unchanged in
foreign films by foreign film that
you're not english-speaking and it has
to be released other than your native
territory it has to be in our house in
some ways they're more interesting in
some ways they're better movies what I
really want to say that very often the
best movie of the year come from this
category yeah if you ask me what's the
best movie last year to me by far by far
they're far as a separation that's the
best movie of last year it was in this
category so a foreigner now I think this
is the most interesting category of of
the Oscar it's very special
I really want to congratulate all the
nominees this year it's a great
achievement
they should be very proud of when you
represent our countries
we'll take pride in our culture's and
where he had the Oscar that's really
great
I want to salute to them and I believe
you're enjoying hearing those great
filmmakers talk today thank you
now it's my honor to introduce our
moderator for today and the previous
chair of the Foreign Language Committee
Marc Johnson brought fresh energy and
new ideas to the academies appreciation
of foreign language film the proof that
Marc is irreplaceable as the moderator
is that he hasn't been replaced here's
Academy award-winning producer and great
advocate for foreign language film Marc
Johnson
good morning I would like to say I don't
know how long I had been the chair of
this this category and I got so used to
myself doing it it was very hard to see
Ron and Bruce take over they did a
spectacular job I really want to thank
them and they had extreme budget cuts
you should have seen the catering it's
much better when I was chair without
further ado the most one of the before
we bring up the directors I would love
to tease you with some clips of the
movies those of you have seen them he'll
be reminded of how wonderful these five
nominated films are and those of you who
haven't this will truly be a tease she
suppose he native seed easily did give
opportunity to unfurl a shave you have
gene sister Peggy it a shitty don't eat
you this is pass just yeah and cuckoo
similar and this is fast and this is
best
yeah
and share digital and forgot my whiskey
yeah
and
matific well Joe Vuli salut [ __ ] did
okay Skeeter if to complete no further
citrine black don't see didn't present
healed so Sylvania presently quad kill
presently from Campania soccer to tune
percocet poem good another to see patrol
came upon you Chris kiss pass pocket una
pelea G aqua grabber to Casa La Land
stone 50 play Doom Australia Pacific
island to be certain between - Sylvia -
Keegan Sir Percy me kiss kiss a don't
pass a duty lashes yoga dill olive Aggie
tuna para proteger [ __ ] no disc is
passe GP suit of shontella position
research in a Parisian Georgia
yeah got a partial Tucker
city city co nihilist you're doing it
yet I usually don a shampoo for maybe a
shoe delicious city Saku Saku a feature
of America beanie we positively see
locally from Co papa nope you
hi
no it was stroking across this one
Easter Umbra can be Turkish LaRosa
sanction Stein
frost mops will be a long to survive
tonight
yeah compare that Koosh
without an extra heart
oh sweet debates are all in your our
liver failure
- Ottoman Turkish Royal Norwegian
Embassy Washington DC from toradol
Contiki May 17th 1947 58 seconds south
zero Niner seconds west the raft is
keeping up well we are on our way and
morale is high having had the problems
with the radio we have been unable to
establish contact wind conditions see
Cuba lotta focus airflow in London FM -
Samir the ups or anything
Thanks
thanked bureau hi in this it vividly
no dear Jaime on the sofa karma :
Wildmutt super what I made that the holy
spirit cela que lo que van American
penis on the Mercado intraday locked
well context associa the petal
oi chile pienso photo
yeah
todo lo que tiene okay okay look come on
Kate
mom Estella Campania viento memory so
commerce LT coca-cola okay
Tillis and o una lengua Kapoor is otário
que universal familiar attractive o
optimist
pero Armando concept of political a trap
we gotta get opposite of my gender
perfect him and take a I do not see me a
lovely a probl a bully see ya tonight
I'm panning intended anyone keep in
unity to overt Madigan came I pick my
team motherboard grounded to play C 2h
Lamia li toora loora no grander Iago no
same ol ok a bizarre when tiempo que
también entiendo que me the headache oh
no / don comedy ama trainer severe to -
sorry zo Sandoval is yeah bruh
Randy Capriccio no / d un poco lebretia
sir thomas VM Kanade Rovia Valencia
penguin Vanessa briceño tengo mean mejor
amigo yo yo yo una compañía Svensson mo
y realmente
represented to alert Tina get the
present el dolor de todo and Balu crown
they look Lou get to know you know say
you wear one what's it going and you
know perfect I'm I think it's
- blonde man it's on a companion Paris
in a Cell look a real mentally I mean we
were trying for number was gonna go
Panero mio mio que - they placed a pata
me em no no no lo que Jovi why look at
Eddie's son Raymond SS imagenes solo
Kutesa see Ricardo you know to Punto de
Beaufort ain't no way a fair country say
they aren't poker if toreano comes on
you wanta I think the way he director
went there to mother under the treaty oh
yeah mmm / - Seneca done in place you
know partido query porque okay um
represent out oloppor to political
easily there see see i said colo color
geopolitical attendance a political
representa
esta por ejemplo el el rojo capo 10 take
a muy fuerte de Cali
stylist wool and my parents are cooler
Sarah Tiana very thick a totalmente
social demócrata style including certain
then say Oh baby a balloon the
denominator democrática poor tangos
differential
there's my state thank you sir
de Lucas muscly paper half-demon mango
staining
20 no one's seen ago before you [ __ ]
killed me in here thanks girl
Vanessa and Scott are loosening satisfy
if I do mellow fight for good on this
half
the fire yeah
before that's gonna show a new tooth
Bennifer
scary so badly crustal smile Blair so
hard needs the source of be offer
Elias fantastica Tonka no Atlantic
appear
the alleys among the photos of your
office Thomas to pee
I mean met panelists before you sir
that's why I sell a Clow or my inclusive
City harbor costume and still graduate
the bottom
Roberto Escobar
no comment some fines golf not heavy
sadness or that here so I mean fart
c'mon eat often first thing I'll say it
and hit officeholders girl it's joked
detector we all know miss kitty a
surface I did escape death Jim askew
also donated as icing that's what we
could be princess is gone Kristen
let's hope you to be gone for scare mr.
teleportal mark any concern if you
believe normal eating that again just
say Galaga but then because it was a mr.
Guzman
be simple tailor or you gonna die a scar
mr. sake do you know me I'm a limo I
conceal amy has got an elderly for
fitness nice for Studios appearing stock
eg me ask if I could feel as she touched
net a us our fan there's my state yeah
when questioned and shooting a clear
here Molly Moll Lord pray often or
pharmacist carrot Reagan's among me
admit Ferguson
oh boy lately certain campaign is go
cotton ball
yeah division society Bob pinkness
caffeine's vs care it minta believe upon
showing honor for them to study her
insect a fatass cosas out there for that
PC if you are known function we make it
as my state fleein at me
Oh oh come on scallions tears malamar
concern
Ashraf diversity demova this year a lot
for comedy comedy Davinia sorta weekly I
bet it could be a cardiac or to instruct
us casting for target complaints a
qualified otama advocate short demo vada
Pascal controversial TV Priscilla Bondi
vomiting yourself host birthday me she
Kumasi affair like Kanye belt Ducati
quiet so venomous Ishita marvelous
Veta Bongo masazi
Veta Bangu Musashi
Donna sucio Bhoomi Bangu du Bangu drama
[ __ ]
become an opossum India
come on Sarah will be boom Ebisu
before Mirabelle yeah
apples and oranges that's an expression
that suggests things that are impossible
to compare and when we have this morning
and indeed tomorrow night at the Oscars
themselves are five movies that are
virtually impossible to compare and to
contrast and virtually impossible to
decide which one film is the best of the
five a sublime meditation on true love
and exhilarating recounting of an
impossible ocean voyage a political
upheaval orchestrated by a Chilean
Madison Avenue a grand historical
account of doomed love affair that was
too the key to a political and social
undermining of a nation and a violent
and magical tale of constricted girl in
modern-day Africa all of these films are
the five films that the Motion Picture
Academy is recognized as a nominees this
year's foreign language Oscar and each
one of these films succeeds gloriously
on its own and by its own terms
certainly not by a yardstick measured
one against the other
I've been moderating this panel for nine
years and I can't think of a year in
which our five nominated films were so
different from one another and the made
the marking of an Oscar ballot so
difficult so conflicting and ultimately
so satisfying the nature and of own
awards race or a film festival favorite
demands that there be a winner those are
the rules of the game and while sunday a
winner will be revealed I can't help but
feel that the real winner is the
committee member who had the sheer luck
of seeing each one of these five
exceptional films all five of these
films all six of these directors have
reminded us why this category exists why
it's so important to the American
Academy and why the constant celebration
of foreign language film subtitled
movies is so important to American
movie-going apples and oranges I now
like to bring up each director or
directors and in the case of case of
kontiki for you to meet and hopefully
will
we'll have a nice conversation over the
years this has been one of the best
events I believe not because I had
anything to do with it but one of the
best events of Oscar weekend and it's
such a great opportunity to do - to meet
and to hear what some of the best
directors of the world are up to our
first I reckon I'm going to bring up has
been here before it just seems like
yesterday he was sitting here probably
in the exact same place with Robert gray
his translator also for a white ribbon
he is a certainly no stranger to the
foreign language Oscar category and
that's Michael Chanukah
before I bring up the next directors
is there anybody from your cast or crew
who's here today you'd like to recognize
yes redirect yeah
three of the producers of the four
producers we are they become Hudspeth
Heather Scott I'm Stefan
where's the fourth producer Margaret
many goes she will come this evening
okay good I just always want to make
sure the producers reckless she was
picking up the scissors oh oh that our
next director is is from Canada Canada
is quite a streak in this category we've
had the past two years a Canadian film
has been nominated we had was here Lazar
last year in the year before that it was
on tondee's but Kim is new to new to
this this this grouping here so please
the director of Warwick Kim new yen
hi Kim what about you do you have cast
cast and/or crew here yeah everybody
decided to fly in we have a lot of
people we have my producers Pierre and
Manny Claude and we have our whole
logistics team and a lot of actors are
DOP Nicola Duke at art director emanuele
flechette and he flew in from Kinshasa
yesterday night and was ready to walk
the red carpet tomorrow
Rachel Mwanza who's made it here really
happy
if you would all of the all of the cast
and crew you just mentioned where they
could you please stand yes please
our next director is from Chile and we
saw a spectacular film of him because of
his a couple of years ago that was
submitted Tony Manero and it's so good
to have him have him represented in what
I want to talk to him about it because
it's a part of this is the last film of
a trilogy that he's done I won't find
out exactly what that what the nature
that that trilogy is and why it is a
trilogy and doesn't just keep going the
director of know Pablo Loreen
what about you would you have cast and
crew here yeah it's wonderful it's my
brother producer of the film Juan de
Dios Laraine is better baby I know the
writer also here it's unfinished acres
or so my wife and I start a film and
also as Gael Garcia Bernal gear also
Vanna Dreyfus producer as well is there
and then produces from Chile modeun
latina Rocio
by the way guile has a distinction of
having starred in three movies that have
been nominated in this category our next
rector is the director of a royal affair
from Denmark this is a category that
seems from Denmark that Susana beer
seems to have dominated over the past
couple of years very happy to to have
here with us Nikolaj our cell
thank you and we all get to keep these
these pieces of paper with their names
on them very important great what about
you cast and crew here yes I have some I
have a crew here I have a whole Danish
delegation with me I have two both three
my three very very talented very
powerful very stubborn very beautiful
producers who I would like to stand up
Louisa ves me safar Leia and she's
Graham Johnson
and and I have my uber boss the boss of
cent Roper is your Peter OPIC and the
rest of the Danish delegation please
stand up so we can see you everybody yes
thank you
now if I'm correct in reading the
credits to your film there are a total
of 18 producers executive producers
co-producer and associate producer is
that right that's that's probably right
yeah well that's how it is you know we
have to find if it's slightly more
expensive than what you normally could
manage on a Danish project you have to
get a lot of producers from elsewhere
and financially for them in a lot of
countries perfect and then we have
excuse me from Norway two directors
whose film we saw it seems like also
another couple of years ago max Manus
which was really spectacular and they've
they've topped themselves so the
directors of kontiki we have Yorkie
Marone running and espen sandberg
I feel like we're a basketball team
starting something high-fiving one
another these guys I've been with we
were all together last night and then
again this morning they seem to get
along so well and you most of you have
just met for the first time I'm just I'm
assuming but it's a phenomenal
camaraderie I'm gonna start off with a
question that I always do which is what
it was the genesis of your film how did
it how did it come about and and do the
two of you we'll start with with the two
of you do you always work together and
this will and and we we have seen many
of us have seen the documentary that was
I believe in 1950 is that right the the
original or 1952 but 52 raid present our
cast and crew as well oh my gosh I
totally forgot so a huge delegation from
Norway so if we could have a tour hard
oh it's Paul Hagen and its crew please
stand up together with
this is this is what they in their fight
would applaud song and then we also have
yeah I think yeah
producers okay and Jeremy Jeremy
Tomlinson or Goldberg a screenwriter
Petter skavlan the editors and the sound
designers are also here please stand up
thank you yes so to go back so sorry
we'll go back to what was the genesis of
this film how did you come about doing
it and why why now well we are from this
small town in Norway called Sandefjord
and and we wanted to make movies because
of you guys the members of the Academy
and all the wonderful movies we grew up
with and it was a tough thing to say
back then that he wanted to be a
director and luckily in our neighboring
town Larvik there was this guy tour
Heyerdahl and he had certainly succeeded
in sticking his nose out and become very
famous so we visited of course his kids
the Museum in Oslo
and there we saw the raft and underneath
the raft when you walk into the basement
there's this huge whale shark and it was
just a very powerful image and Bloor
mines basically and then as you walk out
as you leave that there's a small window
and in there is the what first and the
only Oscar ever won by a Norwegian and
that was tore hard all he won it in 1952
for the kontiki
documentary so that was a huge
inspiration obviously and yeah I notice
also that you have 14 producers on your
film yeah I think it is like that when
the moment you you start you know going
outside the comfort zone of
normal Scandinavian budget you have to
bring bring on a lot of people and on on
contiki there's 24 different financing
sources from 7 different countries that
explains it
Nicolai what about what about you how
did how did your film come about I had
read that this is a piece of history
that that is obviously so well known by
every school trial and yet no one has
done a done a film version no that's
right and I was really wondering about
that and it turns out there's a reason
why this film hasn't get made until now
because I found that out after I wrote
the scripts then it took five years to
finance the film and get it made so it
was a that's why it didn't happen before
because it's sort of slightly expensive
in terms of a Danish film and and and it
and it's a risk in Denmark where we are
more known for this what I call kitchen
dramas which is more about you know
modernized stories about divorce and
death and and sort of the period drama
had sort of had its day in the 80s and
and nobody really wanted to do anything
like that
but so it was quite hard to convince
actually the finance used to to spend
money on a Danish period drama ended you
to have multiple finance hairs I did I
did we had a lot of finance years and
you know since Hopa had to really
stretch the wallet in various so it was
a it did take some time but ultimately
you know we got there Pablo but what
about you and I'm really curious about
why this is a series of three films and
was it when you when you started for
instance with Tony Manero what was it
constructed as as three films and no
work so perfectly you know on its own
and I understand that it probably has to
do with your sort of what you have to
say about about a regime that you were
you were a child child there during the
heyday yeah well it's
it was absolutely unexpected I run it
under the plan making three movies on
the same subject
in fact this we start work with working
with with my brother and paired with
another writer well we were finishing
Tony Manero so I was like really not
expected at all and I would say I
understand but I would say that it's
depressed mostly who has created this
idea of the trilogy it makes a lot of
sense you know but I'd never plan so I'm
gonna make three movies about this no it
would it be too much maybe um this
clearly Pinochet has real impact and in
all three of them we are aware oh yes of
course no no it makes a lot of sense I'm
not against the idea of the trilogy it's
just I never plan it so it's not
something that really comes from from me
and and this specific movie it's we work
over it because but then I were
interested in you know on on actually on
how they did this campaign and the
curiosity I think was the first sort of
word that I would use to describe it
because it will grow up in this country
that had defeated peanut-shaped
throughout a democratic process
dictators usually don't leave power
throughout the emigrate prosit that's
you know that's quite strange and and
then we realized that the way that he
was pulled out it was with the same
tools that he imposed in my country so
it was an interesting paradox and then
it's a very unknown story most people
know how peanuts are guarded by word but
not most people know many people know
how he got out so I was fascinating in
many levels and it also was the
combination and the crossover in between
advertising and political communication
which is usually very dangerous but I
think this time she really helped so the
story was so fascinating in many
different levels that we we were we were
that we had to like to to talk to the
people who actually did the campaign and
so we were there with them and and we
create this fiction throughout the
arbitrary tree that that movie lets you
and it's been a wonderful journey to
discover how this happened and and how a
such a violent person as spinach it was
pulled out of power throughout the
choice of space and and beauty basically
and and and worthy the the TV
commercials really is benign as you show
in your and your in your film they
really are you saw the scene there but
they really are it's like selling is one
of the character says it's like selling
coca-cola but it was incredibly
effective yeah well everything is
original and I like when I get that
question because it means that it works
because we shot in the same format that
order type of footage was made so the
audience actually don't really realize
what word and that thing is interesting
it's an illusion we were gonna use and
we did use nearly 1/3 of the film come
from archival footage and if we would
shut it on like HD or fame or a regular
state-of-the-art technology it would be
too different from the cable for it so
we really wanted to achieve an illusion
that when movie makes you know and and
we wanted to sort of create a texture
that he would it would belong to a
specific memory and and period and
that's the 80s and at the beginning was
shocking because you're working with
that it's a camera system that has less
resolution than an iPhone you know and
it does really show it's it was quite
dangerous history Square and it's and
it's the aesthetic logic of today it
would say that it's ugly you know and
and when you approach to that you start
working with a defect with a
technological problem that is also
considered ugly and we think that we
deliver us the same as the dictatorship
that it was very ugly they pull him out
with the tools of beauty I think we did
that the same but in in cinematic ways I
believe
it's an extraordinary technique and it
takes a little bit of getting used to
but it is so so wed the style and and
end content in your in your film it's
remarkable kim what about you a
certainly war or which doesn't seem like
canadian film how did how did you come
to this well i read up quite a while ago
this story about the there's two
brothers this guy a nine year old kids
in burma johnny to was a was part of an
army of rebels and he woke up one day
and said he was the reincarnation of god
true story in the 90's i would smoke
cigars every day and would be carried by
a bodyguard that went by the name of
rambo because the whole rebel army
thought that how do you started walking
on the soil it would like it would dirty
his visions because he would call the
shots he would say the Rebbe the
soldiers from the government are gonna
hit here here so we should attack from
there and the sheer madness and like
this living Greek tragedy in modern
times you really compelled me to to see
if there was a story that could be as
powerful as that as that true story so
very quickly I moved from Burma to the
sub-saharan Africa where I went to
Burundi and met ex-child soldiers and
where this kind of strange love story
got entangled into this child soldier
story and and then we went to the Congo
and there was a like a constant
rewriting process as we got closer to to
filming the project and yeah you got fed
by a lot of realities that I discovered
as I went along Michael when when you're
in in that chair three years ago with
the white ribbon was was a more already
in your mind or is it something that
that you arrived arrived that later
I can't remember so so then when the gen
III had had read that this stemmed from
a relationship or a really painful
episode you had with an older relative
and that the idea came from this story
and what happens to this this couple
came from from very personal experience
as well in Atlanta for me a deeper
takeoff Kovacs Infiniti see equipped avi
auntie even had fish on this one I see a
patella following the 88's on my moose
teens an emblem vph met him late and as
mentioned in Italy on TGIF I admitted
the should be part even after day event
well in Finn's among vicente mais was a
gay man he a sportin killer killed on a
smiling man so enthusiastic because that
the diseases healed aware but people
would say i'm sectional about sewing
lesson on cinta mostly an ad for did you
get all that
both will see that Levitan second take
yes the story where the the starting
point for the story was second
experience if my like and who i grown up
with as a child and who I love very much
at the end of her life was suffering
physically uses terribly I was forced to
look on it was a very bitter experience
for everyone involved and let me to
think about the fact how do you cope
with the suffering of a loved one when
you're unable to help them that led me
to reflect on the situation and
eventually to decide that I wanted to
make a film about it of course that
theme isn't
primetime material for the box office so
it took some work to convince my
producers but nonetheless they came on
board and followed me enthusiastically
it's interesting I don't know if the
experience in Europe is the same in the
US I find the number of moviegoers
knowing how good the film is but knowing
what the movies about almost resisting
going because because they they
anticipate too much pain either in terms
of relatives of their own parents
grandparents or impending and pending
age and and yet obviously the film is in
at its base it so it's a love story but
it's interesting that I find so many so
many moviegoers really afraid afraid to
see it almost is that is that true
outside the US no sudden vision until it
meet the press it's attuned Diaz oh not
really shaped this isn't good gimmick
the film aside socially open Athenian
doctors is in film Ibaka I don't oh this
is about Henry Mubarak I don't owe
anybody leeway on this mostly harsh
braking on thumb pain dealer at the
other end I think that has to do with
the fact that the press has presented
the film is a terrible film something so
hard to do and you're a film that's
about illness and death but to me the
film isn't about illness and death but
about love rather and I think that when
people tell each other about it and tell
these what they've really seen on screen
then it works quite well
III couldn't agree more it's absolutely
it's absolutely true and it's it's such
a liberating such a beautiful love story
that it it's interesting that I guess it
is that the press that somehow has told
some of us that this is going to be a
painful experience is just the opposite
they did this for thank you said my name
of all first booze a month I'm afraid
that I'm responsible too it's my
reputation as being someone who likes to
inflict pain on their audiences I'd like
to talk about casting a little bit you
have a fairly contained cast in your
film obviously we start we start and in
South America and made a number of
different people but the core of your
film is what a crew of six six I was
going to say six or seven to what degree
how did you go about casting it and to
what degree did you were you concerned
with authenticity or for instance the
physical or models obviously the of the
real real crew tore hard all is is very
famous in Norway and and has led one of
the most well-documented lives ever and
he's also one of them oh there's been a
lot of parodies of him because he has a
very strong accent Norwegian accent so
it was tricky to get that balance right
but we worked with Paul Hagen that plays
tour on our previous movie max - and of
course he he looks very much like tour
but not only that he he was about to
study biology when he was accepted at
theater school so we also knew that he
would know or on a deeper level and
understand him so he was a natural
choice for us and we made it very
early on and then the rest of the
casting we basically did around him and
he did the casting and in that way we
made him the captain from the get-go and
ended the crew come come close to me a
mutiny the way or did what work is such
a difficult such a hard film to make it
must have strained a lot of friendships
and core relationship well yeah well any
movie is difficult in in in one way or
another we did shoot a month out on the
open sea and we were lucky enough to to
get hold of tour Heyerdahl grandson
actually made the journey as a tribute
in 2006 from Peru to Polynesia and we
were allowed to use his raft basically
so the raft in the movie has actually
made the voyage so that was a great
treat and and it I mean looking back at
it now we only remember the the sunshine
and the hundred sunsets so so but of
course it was it was hard but it was the
the actors were great very very
motivated to do to do a great job nicola
you have really a host of characters a
very large cast but there are three core
core cast members you have a big movie
star you have an an actress who i had
not seen before but the the real
surprise of the film i think is is your
is the is the king and i gather he's an
actor you found who it never was not a
professional actor was in film school is
that right he was in drama school
actually when we found him eating was on
his second year uh or maybe middle of
the third year of drama school and
eating your right he'd never done
anything before this part so it was
quite daunting i think for him and for
me actually it it's for those of you
haven't seen it's an extraordinary
performance because the first blush he
feels feels like a almost a fool
and and Yeti has a conscience and a real
sensitivity and by the end of the film
you you so feel for him and and you you
think from the beginning that that he's
not going to go anywhere where the
emotional devs take him and it's it's
one of those performances one of the
watershed performances really oh my god
who who is that guy yeah you're right I
mean it was it was a little bit it was
quite fun because as soon as we finished
shooting this film which was obviously a
very bad you know huge sometimes
harrowing often very beautiful
experience for us he then had to go home
and take film acting lessons in his
drama school which I thought was
hysterically funny but he did he's a
very nice down-to-earth guy he went in
there he didn't he didn't have any
errors he just went and did these film
acting school's out for the film just
went to went acting school and when they
asked what you've done it so I might
just start in the movie I just did
something a little bit little film Pablo
went in and know how I there some actors
I recognize I certainly recognize from
your your your other films and then you
also had a a big international movie
star
did you have guile in in mind from the
very very beginning were the two of you
friends and had you talked about it
before it was written or is it something
just happened in the the casting process
we thought about in before we we started
even writing the script yes we always
wanted to to have a girl it's just a lot
of people ask me it's a constant
question because he's Mexican and he's
playing the chili role and that she just
you do point out that he just come back
from Mexico is that something you
accommodated for the actor we think with
it was very interesting that the guy who
actually decided not to use violence
it's a guy who actually experienced the
Exile so it was even more interesting
and we thought about him because he's a
wonderful actor you know because we keep
having these questions that did you
invite him because it's
a very well-known actor and so it would
be anything more easy in terms of money
distribution whatever and the reason why
these are well-known actor is because
it's a great actor you know so it's like
what's first you know and his being able
to skateboard had nothing to do with him
she used to yeah when I one day I wanted
to I thought about the skateboarding I
called him I said would you do it and
and he used to be a very good at
skateboarding when he was a young but
younger sorry
okay so sorry yeah sorry yeah so your
last movie but yeah so yeah he banished
he actually did all the the
skateboarding shot himself yeah oh no
you can tell that he that he did and
then the rest of the cast is well it's a
it's my wife who plays guys wife this
year too
yeah Alfredo Castro and and most of the
the people that I've been working with
in the last six or seven years so we are
like a little company that instead of
doing theater we do movies we just
changed our of the roles of them and
it's fantastic we just created and a way
of working we do understand each other
and and it's been for me created because
these people this probably the the
greatest actors in my country and and
not all of them of course there's a lot
of great actors to for them so I said
it's really an honor for me to have them
in all these movies Kim your cash I'm
assuming is almost all non-professional
and in is that right yeah I think it we
could say it's about 75 percent of the
cast is we're not actors which all of
you know we have three actors who are
who are from Canada who are here today
and yeah most of the actors are not
actors the way we did the casting which
is we just did a basic your typical open
call session but there was there had
been a
Belgian a documentary that was made
before and people who worked on that
show said well this there's this one
girl you have to meet her name's Rachel
and she's just you know mind-boggling ly
good and they turned out to be you know
right so how did they know that what had
they seen her doing they were doing a
documentary where there was like this
part where they were following kids from
the streets and Rachel was part of that
gang that they followed they just filmed
follow them walking around the streets
of Kinshasa which is the capital of the
DRC of the of the Congo and yeah so she
she was living on the street Rachel from
the age of six has been living it was it
was living in the streets was abandoned
by her parents and when we found her
when we casted her she was living in and
out of her grandmother's place and she
at one point if I remember remember
correctly correct me Rachel if I'm wrong
her grandmother said well you have a
better chance if you go on the streets
and make it on your own then if because
I just can't provide for for you you
know and and of course when we when she
was got on board we very quickly
established a reinsertion program during
and after after the fit of the film and
and then the the rest of the casting did
did you build around her which he the
first person who cast uh no not exactly
Congo turned out to have an amazing
talent of raw you know raw acting
capabilities the people I guess I don't
know if it's from the you know verbal
storytelling tradition that's been given
from the past generations but you know
one out of you know one out of the five
actors that we're not actors we just
turned out to have a really interesting
talent and you know such Canyon de who
they call mmm in Kinshasa was the the
the other lead actor turned out to be
just you know a very interesting just
character yeah
Michael is it's it's I can't even ask
you about your casting process you you
have your film stars too
two icons of European cinema people we
grew up with watching my favorite film
of all time is the conformist and she
sees on the weak Trenton young it's it's
it's a perfect film and and just to see
the two of them in your film and of
course I understand why
Isabella bearers is there and you she
was so wonderful in them and the piano
teacher and it's really a it's a two
hander I guess my question is would you
have made the film could you have made
the film without without your two actors
nanny Hilton film you have the
interpreter I think you should even
Katie no only in each keema but a
monorail was unless really can't easy
not really I'll say Oshima monomer this
is me as femme physically are here on
that the see and be seen with imagine a
stenographer LuAnn went up lanagin's Nam
are disgusting Jima meeting diamond
disease artists on the selection be they
a simple wave accuracy the debate stage
Nick no shots pollution the co-anchor
obvious par with Mitchell return tinea
builded no I wouldn't have done the film
without the John retighten you know I
wrote the film for him with a manual and
it would have been impossible for me to
make the film without him with a manual
river was says different I'd seen her as
a young man and been smitten by her in
her Ashima my love but that had been
fifty years ago and since then I'd
somewhat lost her from sight like I
think most of us when it came time to
cast that then I did a conventional
casting I met all the French actresses
of the appropriate age but from our very
first meeting it was clear that not only
was he the best actress but also that
together with Jean we don t know they
formed a very believable couple
Isabella Priya Hot Sauce frenchiephish
field is boosted off from foreigner and
thus it does mocking with this is an
enigma order I believe the shrieks the
casting but the pianist vacant in
weakening pianist and whatever you have
for her George Pataki casted the son are
they sir good
see son nakshatra dollars and neatness
peonies also have a champion eastern
casting he must never under Dimpy and
isn't the best shot river in terms of is
a better pair I knew before starting to
film and writing a script that she would
agree to make it she agreed to play that
supporting role for reasons of
friendship the most difficult part to
cast was that of the pianist I wanted a
real pianist for the part in fact we
started looking just for actors and the
actors all looked great as actors but
you could tell they were actors so I
then did a casting with pianists and it
turned out that exalteth that ho who
played the part was also have not only a
gifted pianist but also a gifted actor
had he never acted before
it's I had I had read somewhere that you
had to talk both actors both the manual
and generally returned to you know into
doing the film that their initial
impulse was that they weren't really
interested is that true Jana
Shawn we had they said from Virginia on
Canon field maybe mark those authors
private and going food by family and
Ashish they had this and they talked up
with the Ashland article it's a good
song on via ham Smith at least for Sue
there's a hot embarrassing band in the
fancy rescission fashion they not see
luggage both on the film Addington so
good key fine
does a MV maka but there was vanity
which may have easy called us too sure
I'm only as he had Suzanne does a small
over here I would so activist Martin yes
you're right John we continue hadn't
appeared onstage on-screen brother for
15 years for reasons having to do with
the personal tragedy as some of you may
know his daughter was murdered and after
that he withdrew from his professional
career but I used to some trickery to
Braden room on board we hired him to
read the French narration of my previous
film the white ribbon and he liked it
very much and agreed to play the role
but it did involve some risk for me to
write the scripts politically for him
without being certain that he would
agree to play the part on the answerable
saying how do you know
with an inventory argument that we
berated by a hottie secretly with
American Bank a poem on canvas and
retardant at the sahiba league as I'm in
talks in the house if you were dreaming
again making Palmer fan will renovate
auto fan con on what is he hasn't been
intimidated same exact a can Xion are
helping in the search worse than three
mother Satine tell me what sake
the French my French producer Margaret
many girls also managed to convince him
she knew Johnny be quite well Jean we
had broken his leg and on the way back
from hospital going home the taxi his
thoughts where he was looking out for
trees thinking which tree could I crash
into and and my life and he told
Marguerite this and Marguerite came up
with a great argument saying make the
film you can kill yourself afterwards it
it's the remarkable thing about movie
stars because we we know them so well
and they Bing as we say baggage to
everything but these are these are movie
stars we haven't seen in such a long
time so it's it's very much like seeing
new people but but we have we have
emotional connections to them and it's
it's it's you you use the two of them so
so beautifully and they they you you
have to believe that they've done so
many films together and of course they
haven't and it's it's it's they they
make up one of the most most giving and
and convincing couples I've seen in in
many many years on film
I guess
next question really has to do with the
aesthetics and sort of the the both the
aesthetics and the mechanics of making
your film did you obviously knew what
was going to your film kontiki was going
to be be large and that you needed to
sell it on sort of an epic scale so it
was always going to be widescreen and I
think it really is
filmmaking of the highest highest
caliber one of the things that a number
of us are still shaking our heads over
is how spectacular your visual effects
are and I think it's almost impossible
and I've been involved I produced the
Narnia films I've done a lot of visual
effects I could not believe the visual
effects budget that you were you able to
pull off some of the you know as I say
some of the most convincing beautiful
visual effects I can I can think in in
recent history and completely completely
natural did you do it did you do it all
in was it all done in Norway and
obviously you'd had some experience with
max Manas on it too but you were doing
you were doing animals you were doing
some very specific creatures and then of
course you were you were expanding as
spanning sets and and it's it's it's
just a remarkable remarkable achievement
how did you pull it off and how do you
even more importantly have the
confidence to know you could pull it off
well we didn't really have the
confidence but yeah I mean it's the film
has over five hundred effect shots so
and it just kept on on growing basically
as we started shooting yeah it was it
was very daunting going into having to
create all of the animals in CG in in in
as enough as a computer-generated
effects and I am I very much remember
the first
time that we saw a scene with the CG
sharks in it it was the scene where one
of the crew members
pull pull the shark open on deck on the
raft and and kills it and that's a
completely for those of you seen the
film that's completely it's a skate
that's a Scandinavian shark as you say
and I remember crying because we I mean
we were so relieved that we that we that
it worked and that was the first time we
really got the feeling that this was
going to be okay and that was after
three years of working on the film so so
of course it is you you work without a
safety net when you when when we create
our shots like that and it was always a
huge goal for us to create an experience
of nature because that was such a huge
part of the riddle of the raft voyage
for the futur and his crew and you know
these days seeing the BBC documentaries
and even the Disney animal documentaries
they are so amazing and they're getting
more and more amazing every year with
the new digital technologies but of
course we we didn't have time to wait
you know four years for this whale shark
to mate under our raft or whatever it's
so so but that was our you know goal to
compete with that and put our our action
and our characters into that and in
worthy where the effects are all done in
a house in in in Norway were they were
they often of course when you're doing
larger films like that and five hundred
effect shots is a lot they're farmed out
to different different houses or where
they're all done done by the same place
in Norway we had two in Norway and two
in Sweden that did everything and were
they so you had one house for fur for
instance for the Sharks and another one
for set extensions and another one for
painting yeah yeah they were divided out
and
what we realized as we went along we
also shot for a month in the malt movie
tank or whatever they call em and what
also added up was that we were hoping
that the tank was going to have a seemed
seamless horizon as the water kind of
dips over at the end it's a huge tank
basically as big as a football field and
we had our had a raft in the middle of
that and it's a it's a seamless horizon
and but that didn't really work so so
also a lot of I'm sure there's a hundred
shots which is just we had to go in and
paint horizon basically because and also
when we were shooting offshore or Malta
in the Mediterranean
we were never more than a mile or two
offshore so of course we didn't have a
complete clean horizon also with the
ships and and stuff going on so when we
shot we shot one way we did the dialogue
seemed like that for instance and when
we did the reverse shot in the dialogue
scene we had to rotate the raft around
to get the clean horizon so you know but
after a couple of days we got we got
into it how in the world did you get the
tiger and the oh that's another movie
exactly I wish I wish that film came out
two years ago so we could use it for
reference all three of you have made big
sort of big I almost re to use it the
expression you'll know what I mean
Hollywood movie it's very big beautiful
as an audience member you're feeling as
though you're what having a movie
experience you were all shot in and
widescreen they are really big colorful
that sort of so perfectly mounted
mounted films did you did you always see
see your and by the way I read that you
you had to go to you shop most of the
film in in Prague is that right is that
was for a budget reason or is that
because it gave you the scale that you
needed to bring that really satisfying
move
experience there was definitely about
the scale and also about just finding
locations that were true and that looked
real and streets no Street and coke
making looks remotely like you know
it'll used to look in the 1760s but you
can actually go to Prague and and and
they've quite beautifully kept some of
these old Street and restored them and
they look very sort of authentic and so
we could shoot some of these street
scenes there we we also we loved going
to the theatre and we feel that there is
so much great drama on TV these days so
so we love these epic movies we want to
make them ground we want to give the
audience a reason for going to the movie
theaters royal affair and kontiki were
they all shot digitally or on on film we
we felt ours digitally we shot on film
you may not be doing that much longer
ever I know I know it's horrible I will
miss it why why did you decide to shoot
on film because I'm just a little bit of
old-fashioned and no actually there's a
good reason for that and it also it
actually also answers your last question
about the whole Hollywood type of
filmmaking that I think we are very much
the same generation and when we talk
about where idols are they are always
exactly the same which is a little bit
annoying actually
can we have different idols no I you
know when people ask me back home and
say what films do you really love and
what are you watching again and again I
will often say films like gone with the
wind or you know Lawrence of Arabia and
they will always look at me like what no
god ah no you know where's the French
new-wave where's the and I'm always I
was free I grew up on these fake you
know big scope type of films and I
really like that but I but I really
wanted to try and get that I think it's
it's hard with the digital I haven't
tried it yet but there's something about
the medium of film some
about that still you can sense that it's
shot on film I don't know if it's just
in my subconscious or if it's real I
think it's real and I hope that people
will still keep filming ok well that's
why I asked the question because both
both both films seem like they were shot
on film and last year we had joseph
joseph cedar was here and he talked
about the psychology of an actor knowing
that it's celluloid going through the
camera as opposed to it a chip and he
actually felt that it's a little it's a
little tough done that could totally
understand but that psychologically the
filmmakers and the actors had a
different approach to it there was
something more about it not so much
old-fashioned filmmaking but there was a
sense of moviemaking I guess to it so
well we are we are the first of the
video generation so Espen and I we we
grew up making our short films on on
video we never touched film until we
came to film school you know we were 20
so so and we always loved shooting on
film we max mannix was shot on film and
we really resisted the digital format
for a long time until the Aria Alexa
came out and I think that really changed
it and also in Kentucky being so many
effect shots it was something we decided
that we had to do because of the you
know the the high quality of the of the
red and we also did it because of the
actors and the acting because then we
could we would not run out of film you
know we could continue and it was
important for us because it we were on
this raft with so many actors at the
same time and to keep going and just
have a conversation with them basically
when we were shooting was crucial we had
140 terabytes of data when we were
finished so it's a lot and we shot it in
two languages so oh that's right I
wanted I forgot that I had heard that
you had had you did you really do two
takes in other words you'd get a print
in in your Norwegian version and then
doing
language version that's correct we did
it so there's the movie coming out here
in the states in in April is the English
version and this the sad thing for our
actor playing tour Heyerdahl is that in
the English version we had to take his
strong accent away because it would pop
out like a sore thumb so you had to do
those scenes twice as well even the
English scenes I'm afraid we're gonna
have to disqualify you from the foreign
language so I our for filmmakers here so
now going from these big Hollywood
widescreen colorful films of theirs come
to yours and I gather you've you've sort
of retrofitted old old video cameras
it's a spectacular look and it goes once
again as I say it's so fits fits the
film but it takes some getting getting
used to and as you guys could all say
from the clips it's it it is not it is
it is a little bit of a grainy image and
it's little bits not nearly as sharp as
as for instance their films but it it so
much says not just about the period but
by the enterprise of of advertising
itself yes it's it works in different
levels we used this in 1983 Iike gummy
chip cameras which is actually the very
first video system they were that was
ever created that's the look it's not
how you record it it's the technology
that you used to grab the image and I
was just telling this really low
resolution and it has it it had we hire
a company here in Hollywood who actually
bought 20 cameras all over the United
States and they assembled for for us and
every camera had a different look
because it's just they were so old and
different so and they would react
differently on the set depending on the
light conditions so it was a whole
nightmare at the beginning because the
cameras didn't really work very well
it was very hard to know when they were
in focus or not if one is a camera I
would match the B camera and and it was
a whole nightmare but then when we start
editing I went I remember I went one day
when we were shooting today eating a
room and then under-18 Yoli was the
editor he showed me a bunch of things
and then a bunch of things from their
title footage and at some point it was
like who shot that you know and and we
were confused with it we had to call
today like somebody else who tell us
exactly is that what came from their
kind of food it's something that we shot
yeah because and then we realized that
we were creating something with just
like their cattle footage and then we
send if sent a very first car - to her
friends here in participant media and
then one of them caller said a man be
noted is he really looks like like be
nurtured you really did a great no no
man he actually spinach a so and and
when you do that it's it's interesting
because what do we shot it became
documentary and the documentary parts
became fiction and that's a very true
crossover and and yeah and had sergio
armstrong shot your other films - oh yes
yeah and did did he worry at all about
about having the film come out that
maybe didn't look too good and people
would say gee I don't know about that
about that camera man yeah he haven't
been nominated ever in any in any in any
film festival for prefer ography which
is I think it's a mistake because it's
it's much easier to work with a super
camera that it would deliver immediately
a very nice image than to illuminate and
light said with a camera that is
actually really ugly
you know so it's a it's a whole
challenge for to do that and and I think
yeah at the beginning it was very
worried and my brother the process here
was keep asking for us to have another
sort of HD camera
said to cover it you know like just
habit and just wait who do you care and
just love it there and you don't frame
for the chief or to it for that you know
then and we were come on let's just
that's this is it let's do it just with
that's cameras and and yeah it we get
used to it and and and we just don't
loving it you know and and and you sorta
just start to get used to it and and
then when you get to see now regular
movies they look so sharp you know and
and and so this is also a protest a
little protest against the a Germany as
of HD by the way your your brother
sounds like a very good producer I would
have said the same thing just in case
it's sort of like a struggling to do a
black and white film and every producer
every studio exec you say that's great
that's great that's very artistic make
sure you have it in color also Kim what
about you
there is looks like the the bulk of your
film is is handheld is that right yeah
we shot the film with the Alexa and we
benefited from this there were always
these tires burning in Kinshasa and
always fires going around so we had this
beautiful constant yellowish smoke all
over which was a great light filter we
had just the right amount of Sun on our
actors and but it was filtered so that
was really great and and yeah is the
third film I do with with Nicolas who
won the Golden Frog this year with this
film Academy imagine in Poland Congrats
Nicolas and I I call Nicolas we're like
five-year-olds on the set were really
really like basic humor we do these
silly jokes and I call him jell-o joints
because he's I don't know how he does it
she just runs around to the camera
completely fearless he always has these
these grips and he's like he would run
backwards knowing there's a staircase
and he he would still just go running
backwards and hope that his grips would
catch him when he's gonna he's about to
trip you know so yeah that's how
fearless he is so
I'm really grateful for his courage did
you always end it's interesting
something you guys haven't in common did
you always plan to have the voice-over
and basically heavier lead actress
talking to her unborn child and your
particular case you have your lead
actress talking to her two children who
she will never never see again was that
something you you had from the very
beginning did you arrive at that later
the the actual premise of the script was
actually that that inner voice and I had
read accounts of X child soldiers who
wrote you know small biographies like
three paragraphs and reinsertion
programs and I saw like very you know
touching things like we weren't allowed
to cry so we had to learn to let the
tears leak from inside or I hope that
I'll be able to love my baby when he
gets out because you know he was a
product of rape you know from her
soldiers so all of these these things
were the basis of the narration what is
it what is eerie is that before leaving
Kinshasa we worked for two weeks with
Rachel trying to do the voice-over
because her French got like really
better as the set as the filming went on
and it wasn't yet on par with you know
something that people could clearly
understand but it was the basis of like
the soul of the character through that
voiceover what was there on tape and we
found actually in Montreal a run DS girl
who went through the genocide in 93 and
it's her voice on the on the screen and
I guess it's just her natural you know
in her voice of what she's been through
that is projected on in in the audio
actually speaking of her I felt after I
saw your film that for a long time I
thought it must have been two actresses
because she starts as such a young girl
and then which she becomes pregnant and
she's she's a full woman at the end of
the film not so much just an aging
process of just how what this character
has been through in the course of the
course of the film I was convinced that
it was to two sisters well there's
something I must say that pragmatic
leads something really we decided to
shoot this film chronologically and we
didn't show the the script to the actors
IRA would reveal elements from this from
the story as we started we filmed and
they were directed improvisations
although all the scenes and the
dialogues were written we still went to
an improvisation process and there's a
great there's a there was a craft
service right and Rachel didn't eat that
much before the set and she gets
pregnant in the movie and she eats a lot
of food during the set she actually
gained like 15 or 20 pounds during the
film which was perfect best special
effects ever true De Niro I wanted to
ask you also did you always plan to have
the voice-over because you use it
considerably I mean it works beautifully
but is that something was that an
afterthought no that was not that was
actually planned and and in did it it's
got to do with the fact that you we know
that Queen Caroline did writes a lot of
letters and she had a very clear and
very strong voice as well so that was
plan for me from the beginning
Michael I I recognized aesthetically
your your massan's and from from your
films from your previous films and yet
in a more I see a a juxtaposition
between wide shots or wide medium shots
and close-ups and you play entire scenes
almost all sometimes in almost wide
shots conversation there's one scene I
think the first thing with Isabella bear
that is played in rather conventional
filmmaking would have us go in at some
point into a close-up or a two-shot or
over the shoulder and it works so
perfectly it gives us a sense of almost
a strange Minh and and a little bit of
fear throughout it and the very I
believe it's the first shot of the film
which is of our two lead characters at a
recital and we it it's
the shot is several minutes long and
it's if you hear and both the two lead
actors are not in them in the center of
the frame they're off to the to the left
slightly and yet we find them we know
that that those two characters of two
characters we're supposed to play with
do you do you storyboard your films you
know exactly what the the framing is as
you when you go into a scene yeah could
you translate it well I I just for the
life of me the confidence of your of how
you direct the film and of seeing some
shots and knowing as I say once again
it's nothing more than pure confidence
that you know that that we are going to
stay with that scene with those
characters and we don't need to added
information in fact it's almost an
interruption to to cut to a close-up
obviously their close-ups in the film
that they're used so sparingly and my
guess is in a more there probably is one
one-third the number of cuts that there
are in a conventional film forget about
a Michael Bay film but a conventional
film and and it is I'm sorry to say you
feel like you're in the hands of a
master storyteller
now most my sorted in true Shaw Ted came
denting and so forth as a film is a
manipulation on manipulation Asia and
physician a flash this aha moment and
relief assumed in one important zone so
getting remarried so hard on this issue
some discount concept I remain a film a
the swing of feel the plan sequence and
we're assuming the state said in manipur
yet this is a simple concept Esther we
believe this in human form in the Tommy
I want to give her my audience time to
reflect if all of the scenes
film is always about manipulation but
information
something that is bad in itself so I try
to manipulate the audience as little as
possible it's this really the precept of
all of my films that it's the reason why
sin so many films I use single shorter
scenes I want to give the audience time
you know how this will be variant isms
affect the aquatarium this via a Dan
guns a hordes same cannon when we merge
said um once again I'm pretty kinky
through V and we're used to have images
imposed on a circuit and rhythm imposed
on us that I think the audience feels
relief when it's allowed time to find
its own point of view its own
perspective in the images and in the
frame it's absolutely true it's it's one
and one of the arguments usually for
widescreen that that we're not told
exactly what to look at we can be the
the frame is more democratic and we can
we can pick out what it is we want to
want to see there and I've seen that in
your films and listen from the last shot
of cachet but nevertheless we somehow
know we know exactly what it is that
we're supposed to pay pay attention to
without your having to guide us
specifically well the same if I hear the
sounds of X doesn't with this video it's
all a matter a question of craft sure I
would say I would say so I was we were
talking last night and I had thought for
the longest time that the apartment was
a set built on a on a stage somewhere it
must have been in order to be able to
pull walls and get cameras back and just
so the the apartment which really
becomes a character in the film and yet
somewhere in the two-thirds of the way
through I looked out a window which I
assume we were looking at what you call
a trans light which is a painting of a
street and then I saw cars going up and
down it and I said oh my gosh we're
really we're on a real apartment but
then Michael told me that it no it is is
a set and that the car that I saw
outside the the window was a was a
visual effect yeah this apartment
buildings - did you take this off and
the sneak
a man can be chosen in team Ayten if we
meet like me treaty hearing after that
say instrument are only positive in as
we must win via does him in any way iron
apartment get rated and head mister
three multi-female a ticket this
wingless Coliseum studio must need to
have a oscar own twist is about
mentioned I'm sure even this apartment
many attended Norman nise trya does its
media shifted to Tunis invasion for good
Kenny moon weather to her fashion eating
angry financing wanted an after when I
directed my videos previously instant
even film it Akita intake so do not
invest a post-production SIA see a
Museum of language key method one of the
it was clear that we were going to have
to shoot in studio when you're dealing
we're working with actors of that age
it's not like when you're working with
forty year olds and youth they can work
a or ten hours days without interruption
if we do a shot in a real apartment than
we instead of being able to shoot in two
months we would have needed four months
so was clear from the very beginning
that we were going to shoot in studio
but the layout of the apartment was the
I took the the my parents apartment it
was a exact reproduction of my parents
apartment not because their story had
anything to do with the story that I'm
telling on screen but rather because I
knew it was so familiar to me that it
gave me ideas that helped me find
solutions when writing the script
however the disadvantage as you point
out was the fact those views from the
windows would have to be digitally
recreated and that made the
post-production process long and
difficult and the the pigeon was I hate
to ask how many how many takes and and
are you sorry you wrote the pigeon into
the into the script
yeah if it Orion if the same film is our
sister the lemurs apartment median trade
wheels museum SS mafia infusion
deterrent in yoshiya Museum where had
they see the event at the
it said nitch pas and and also hype the
hand capo on this of the HUD auction yet
simply happened as a testimony wasn't be
off to him and he's interesting and we
would threat argued leader it on this
one seeker from saddam from alpha 1 T at
the museums in Russia Rama Hartnett
obviously in senior grant I don't regret
that it's in the film but it certainly
was very very difficult to seem to film
the two scenes
what's more Clinton your had broken his
film during shooting broken his hand he
didn't break it on set but he was
actually working with a physiotherapist
to be in shape of the shooting and when
working with a physiotherapist he broke
his hand so that scene was very painful
for him to shoot I don't know how many
takes we did but those two scenes took
us two days of shooting and it was
certainly the most challenging scenes in
the film it's always hard to work with
animals
there's brilliantly active film and the
most challenging scene was the pigeon
sink it's different I'm sorry I left uh
it's difficult to work with the pigeons
because you can't direct them I think
our last my last question really has to
do with music and film and how did you
guys go about about your score because
you would have a really once again you
have a very impressive movie score which
which works beautifully in terms of sort
of the emotional where the motion of the
film is at the right time and yet it's
not in any way overpowering it's there
it's used quite economically thank you
it's your home so the twist that is a
composer and it's just amazing he also
makes music for beer we wanted to sort
of find the sound of Tiki that was very
important for us because that was what
war believes in and he has this faith
that everything is gonna work out so we
wanted to have that spirituality in the
music and
what Soderquist found was this Swedish
jazz musician that actually plays conks
so that's it sounds like some sort of a
yeah it's some sort of a trumpet but
he's actually playing on seashells so we
felt that was a perfect sound for Tiki
yes it's one of the oldest instruments
on on earth I and now that you mentioned
of course I remember that it's right
Nikolai you had Rio in your head and
then I believe another composer to Syria
for yes well the the thing about my
score was that I felt so strongly about
exactly what kind of music that I wanted
that their producers you know kept
sending me all the music producer kept
sending me a lot of samples of various
Scandinavian composers and I always kept
saying yes yes but can it sound more
like a brother Garrett who is my pick
you know I've loved him since Betty blue
and the English Patient the talent mr.
Ripley some fantastic soundtracks and I
kept saying this that in one moment yet
finally he said well here's capital
Gabrielle the hearts
email you know you can try and convince
him to make the music and I was so
fortunate that I wrote a very gushing
email and very you know I'm basically in
love with everything you've ever done
and please ride a little bit of music
for my film because then it will be so
much greater and and he was he said yes
and he was so pleasant it was a
beautiful experience I went to Paris I
worked with him a little bit then he
said go home go away I will ride you
some themes now and then he wrote five
themes for the film which were all
extremely beautiful and I phoned him I
would say Gabrielle is so wonderful
let's talk about where I want these
three themes to go no no that's it
that's the themes they're done I'm done
so that was it that's what I got from
him we've since become friends but it
was a very it must be wonderful to be
this kind of person that just says I
will do this this is it here you go this
is the finished product use it in your
film so
you must have paid him very little
exactly you did it as a favor for me so
that was Pablo I believe there's no
actual composer credit in your film is
that right no there is is there because
I are we just going to say there's music
that really stands out for instance in
the skateboarding scenes and the stuff
that seems like it may have actually
been taken completely from the period so
I didn't I didn't realize that it was oh
this this is some people that is
interesting like a shoe stucco each C
values Schubert yeah and then it's also
a little piece of Mozart and also it's
you must have paid them a lot a friend
over here and then we did carlos cabezas
a Chilean music composer actually
data-score for specific scenes and we
wanted to have the disc or maybe that
that's why you don't remember is that we
really want to hide it I mean if the
music is gonna have a presence that that
was that was going to be the valses that
we used and then when it was going to be
on and like I'm a scene supporting a
specific idea we did in a way that
equally it is almost invisible and
that's how I think that's why I like
when music sits on movies my two
previous movies didn't have no music at
all
and so this is a very big step for me
because now there's another sound and
you know the soundtrack that's right I
was thinking of the also your first two
films not having a a specific composed
score Kim your music is is spectacular
and it seems it's all from I'm assuming
from where you where you shot it did you
have an actual composer or were you
using just music that you found found in
the region or that you commissioned we
right when I was writing the script I
discovered this amazing
afrobeat music and it's actually
angley's it's right next door to Congo
but it's yeah and I sing in Portuguese
so yeah I was just amazed by the by by
that music and more and more what I try
to do one ago and editing is to I never
use temp tracks anymore because you know
you have this rough cut and then
everybody likes the music that you put
on it and and then of course you put the
Rolling Stones and the Beatles and then
everybody loves the thing and then
you're going to you know the final cut
and use and everybody's kind of
disappointed even though the other
things better because your composer has
to match the Rolling Stones and the
Beatles and you can't afford it right
and you can't call them like like he did
so uh so yeah I just asked if I found
this amazing music from the 70s and I I
really asked to check before going and
editing if we could get the rights to
that music and they were the the record
label was really really helpful
and then Michael lastly clearly Schubert
and Bach and Beethoven do you know what
your film is going to sound like while
you're shooting it or before you shoot
it or is it arrived at later
um I'm sure I have about this music
artist is a mercy date woman yes even
was writing the script I knew which
music I would take and and that if ever
Indian means who as Princip really
special feeling in the heritage will
kanima's it also a much built music or
than other left on toronja with mahogany
he might be hiding this wingsu hit me at
the limo of musica austerity which came
as a musical figure winners in team
fights inside I mean with any kept
office women owned by investments to be
nervous Abba fairly reliably
music fairly well the silver pianist and
escape made America the music to having
never knew what was English built with
on a matter of principle
like using music in any of my films I
think that film I see conceived of film
is a realistic medium and in reality
music is only present if someone is
playing an instrument or FM radio is
playing in the background for that
reason that I write my characters in
such a way that the music can be present
in this film one of my Emmanuelle plays
a piano teacher and we're not sure
exactly what Jean Louie is perhaps a
music producer perhaps working for a
record company but that allowed me to
bring the music in however only when the
music is being played by someone on
screen or when a CD is being played well
amour is is playing throughout the city
right now we have your film opens war
which opens is at March 1st March 1st in
LA it's on the March 8th yep
no opened about a week ago is that right
and and your film when did it open in
the US it opened in November I think it
still outs that's how I was going to say
and kontiki the sorry the non English
version opens when 19th of April so
those of you who haven't seen these
films or the ones that are now available
or the ones that coming up I can't tell
you enough what you'll be missing if you
missed them and thank you all very much
you